and let's begin with something that I
saw yesterday that I think we really
need to put in the proper context Chris
and that is the report from NFL Network
that the Giants are taking a very close
look at quarterback
Justin Herbert yes one year after they
drafted Daniel Jones the Giants
studying carefully Oregon quarterback
Justin Herbert a guy they really may
have liked last year if he had come out
but didn't this year they have a guy in
Daniel Jones that they presumably aren't
going to be throwing overboard so Chris
why do you think they'd be taking such a
closer look at Justin Herbert well Mike
we've talked about this a lot right I
mean this is the same conversation we
had 10 days ago or two weeks ago when it
pertained to the Washington Redskins
then why they were doing deep dive into
the quarterback situation yes I mean
they're expecting there could be some
action it's for four the number fourth
pick and they know that okay you know
will it be a team that's worried about
you leapfrogging Miami at number five
and if they do do that you know more
times than not it is for a quarterback
and Justin Herbert I think is widely
viewed right now especially with all the
to a to injury concerns as the number
two quarterback in this draft so they're
doing their due-diligence they're giving
them one last scouting report to really
know the guy one more time so they can
hold the team's feet to the fire a
little bit oh man we evaluated a blow
does he have the big arm whoa great size
great athlete oh I don't know I don't
know if that's enough
you know assets for this trade to happen
we really think this is a really good
quarterback so not ultimately I think is
the biggest reason they're doing that
and you're right Mike I mean the other
thing is that they got to have a lot of
homework on this guy already because
anything I heard last year they were hot
on Justin Herbert if he was going to
come out and had people at his games
constantly so I would think they have a
pretty big notebook on this guy by this
by this point in time yeah and I think
the key is if you are trading out of the
fourth overall spot in the draft you're
not just giving it up because somebody
wants to say hey we picked fourth
they're coming up for a player and the
more you know about the player that the
team would be coming up for the better
suited you are to negotiate in an
effective way in a
that isn't just flying by the seat of
your pants now it would be even more
valuable if you could convince the team
you're negotiating with that you
actually may just take the guy yourself
but that's gonna be a hard sell and
here's the thing we have seen crazier
stuff than the Giants deciding under Joe
judge to go with Justin Herbert instead
of Daniel Jones but I don't know why in
the world Joe judge who's really not an
offensive guru would want to come in
with his own system and want to have his
own quarterback Joe judge comes in as a
special teams coordinator who was a
receivers coach for one year along with
that to maybe remove the stigma which
shouldn't exist for special teams
coordinators to get head coaching jobs
so it's not quite the same as if you're
drafting some offensive mastermind who
has a vision for a system that Dan yeah
this is not this is not Josh Rosen Kyler
Murray is what you're saying would Kliff
Kingsbury the new head coach right I
mean that's that's basically what you're
saying and I agree with you you're right
yeah I mean Joe judge he came from New
England we know that Daniel Jones you
know I think josh mcdaniels was chomping
at the bit to get involved in that
Giants head coaching conversation
because he thought Daniel Jones was a
good football player Daniel Jones is a
doing villain type of guy and persona
the way he handles himself the way he
plays and he's and he's a giant guy is a
New York giant guy so yes they're not
making a play at the quarterback
situation this is strictly for trade
purposes and like you said just so they
have more knowledge of the player for
negotiating purposes when that trade
goes down because you've got the
Chargers at number six who could
possibly want to come up to number four
to get in front of the Dolphins the
Panthers at number seven who may decide
to cut the line to get in front of the
Dolphins and ultimately Chris we talked
about this yesterday the possibility of
the Dolphins just doing the flip-flop
the Giants squeezing them to come up to
four in lieu of trading the pic to
somebody who would cut the line in front
of the Miami Dolphins so again that all
depends upon whether to what extent the
Dolphins the Chargers and the Panthers
covet Justin Herbert nobody is going to
admit to any of that now but this is
just part of the pre-draft process
while everyone kind of feels out where
things are where the opportunities may
be where the trades may happen and this
is all part of the necessary work that
gets done so that the Giants can engage
in a meaningful conversation about the
value of Justin Herbert who would be
presumably the fourth pick unless the
Lions trade down with someone and that
team makes Herbert pick number three
all right the 49ers have picked number
13 and number 31 they picked up the 13th
pick via the trade that sent the Forrest
Buckner to the Indianapolis Colts via
ESPN the 49ers have put out the word
that they are open to trading either of
those spots number 13 or number 31 and
look this is part of the pre-draft
process too I saw a tweet earlier today
that Washington is receiving calls for
the second overall pick in the draft but
they're not intent on moving it yeah
that's that's what happens the week of
the draft the teams with the highest
picks receive calls from the teams that
are lower just just so that if something
does potentially happen on draft night
there is some sort of foundation there
that is in place so you have an idea of
what the parameters would be what the
team is looking for hypothetically those
conversations have to occur now or they
become impossible to execute on Thursday
night Chris especially while we're
trying to do this stay at home draft
that may or may not have some glitches
or may have some issues so the 49ers
have the two first round picks they've
got nothing in round two three and four
they would like to slide back if they
could to pick up more lottery tickets in
rounds two three and four where they
have nothing this year yeah I mean I
think that's it's as simple as that
I mean I think that Kyle shinny and John
Lynch the 49ers they're just letting
everybody know you know right now hey
we're open for business they have a very
good football team as we know and I'm
sure they want to add like you're saying
more picks in the second third round
more depth to their football team you
know they got some guys that are getting
older they probably feel they've got to
fill the holes there four into so this
is not surprising at all as far as what
the 49ers are talking about you know
trading these picks there
not trading to move up I don't think
it's anything like that I think it is
all about you know trading down
accumulating pics if you go down in the
first round there's a lot of talented
football players to be out of the first
32 pics of this draft and I think a lot
of teams are looking at it going okay
yeah you know we're here but if we trade
down six spots we can get a similar guy
with just a slightly less grade just a
few spots down and while doing that you
know we can get more draft picks in the
process of all this so I think there's a
lot of teams in business just like we
talked about with the Giants talking
about that Detroit and I think that's
the biggest reason I look at Thursday
night I'm excited for it because I think
there could be a lot of trades in chaos
especially with this new technological
format we got and when you have a
quarterback that is making more than 25
26 million a year and his cap number
this year is north of 26 and you've got
a pass rusher Indy Ford who's got a big
cap number and you're just two seasons
away from being expected to pay Nick
boasts a huge money the more young cheap
guys you get the better off you're gonna
be you want guys that are coming in on
that rookie weight scale minimum salary
plus a signing bonus based on their slot
you get a lot of those guys and you let
them become the nucleus then you can
have that mix of some highly paid guys
and some guys who aren't getting paid
very much in beyond Bosa and Jimmy
Garoppolo and D Ford the more successful
the 49ers are Chris the more guys are
gonna want to get paid the more guys are
going to be in line to get paid the more
guys you're gonna potentially lose to
free-agency so you better have that
pipeline of young guys and the more
picks you get the more guys you
potentially have to step up and replace
free agents who inevitably will leave
because you can't pay everyone no doubt
about it I mean yeah it isn't you know
hey John Lynch we know he's very smart
Kyle Shanahan yes he's my friend but I
mean he lives this you know that and
we've talked about it you and I off air
and he's constantly thinking about how
to build his team the next move two
moves down the line and also you know
this is a guy that's very into the
history of football and what's made team
successful and what has not
he struck up a relationship with Bill
Belichick we've heard right ever since
the Jimmy Garoppolo trade and I know you
know we've had this I've had this
conversation with Kyle you know yes he's
very aware that New England is New
England because Bill Belichick was
always willing to do the things you
talked about Mike you know low-level
free agents lots of draft picks you know
not spending a ton of money or allotting
a lot of the salary cap to just a very
few amount of guys on your football team
you know I think Kyle Shannon is very
aware of that aspect of trying to build
a team that can sustain hot you know
great level play for a long long time
and I would think this is a big part of
Kyle's thinking process in this than
this whole thing and you hear different
names as it relates to the 49ers like GM
John Lynch Parag Murat a the contractual
mastermind there is no doubt in league
circles though that Kyle Shanahan runs
the show there he might wear it on his
sleeve
it hasn't been established as firmly as
it is that Bill Belichick runs the show
in New England but make no mistake about
it Kyle Shanahan runs that show and if
he wants to trade down if he wants to
pull that trigger that's what they're
gonna do yes that's exactly right I mean
he has full full power he's running the
San Francisco 49ers organization you
know now he's not like you know maybe
the I don't want to say I don't mean
this in a disrespectful way I was kind
of just saying this for a lack of a
better way to say it maybe not quite the
dictator Bill Belichick is in New
England right uh but he's got a great
way Kyle of communicating delegating
responsibilities taking in what
everybody has to say but then ultimately
he's gonna lean on his own football
knowledge and his studies of what he
thinks needs to be done for the football
team
so yes Kyle he's aggressive we've seen
that already in his first few years as a
head coach he's not afraid to make moves
whether it's for D Ford or Emmanuel
Sanders of the trade the trade for Jimmy
Garoppolo hey their first track the
draft they went from pick two to pick
number three so I think you know between
Kyle and John Lynch a lot of football IQ
there and guys that are not afraid to
make some moves to be aggressive to help
their football team he's got a different
personality than Bill Belichick which I
think yeah keeps improving that
dictator' persona plus he doesn't have
the pelts on the wall and or pellets on
the horse whatever phrase you prefer
once you start winning Super Bowls as a
head coach that's when the aura around
you changes and who knows if that
happens once Kyle Shanahan starts to
amass Super Bowl trophies one thing
about the 49ers though if they do use
those two picks number 13 and 31 it will
be the seventh time since 2000 that they
have used two first-round draft picks
that's unbelievable but they have six
prior times during this this century
this millennium used two first-round
picks and I'll tell you what they hit it
big in 2007 with Patrick Willis and Joe
Staley Staley sue on the team and
they're expecting him to play at least
one more year Wow yeah I mean well hey
listen there's there's a reason that we
saw that Jim Harbaugh Trent Baalke team
there in San Francisco be one of the
most dominant football teams in the
league for about a two or three year
period and one of the like Paul Adonis
one of the all off the bus teams like
they were one of those teams Mike when I
was working in New England in 2012 and
pregame watching you know Patrick Willis
Navarro Bowman Joe Staley some of the
other guys that you were like whoa this
is one physical freak after another so
they must have killed it in the draft to
build a team like that but that's
amazing to have that many multiple picks
in the first round that many times so
far this millennium one more note before
we go Peter King mentioned yesterday
that there's a rumor making the rounds
that did Chiefs may try to trade up to
get not a defensive back not a lineman
another receiver Henry rug's who ran the
four to seven at the Scouting Combine I
mean how in the world now first of all
the fact that there's a rumor out there
that the Chiefs are thinking about
trading up for receiver Henry rug's
makes me wonder whether or not they
really are because if they really were
we wouldn't know about it like with
Patrick mahomes we didn't know about it
till what happened but look it has
managed to sneak out that they are
thinking about Henry rug's
tyree kill Sammy Watkins me Cole Hardman
now Watkins in the last year of his
contract with the Chiefs but Wow
Wow if you add and and this way you're
gonna have to do is you're getting ready
to pay Patrick mahomes I think you're
gonna have to draft a receiver every
year because you're not gonna be able to
pay these guys Watkins is gonna be gone
after 2020 Tyree kill will be gone at
some point then me Cole Hardman will be
gone and then Henry drugs if they get
him will be gone and they're just gonna
keep cycling receivers through as the
guys who catch the passes for Patrick
mahomes I think that's exactly right
I mean I think if they're gonna be able
to manage a football team and build it
the right way that yes some sacrifices
will have to be made and yeah you're not
gonna get to keep a receiver for two
contracts and give the guy you know a
hundred million dollar contract on that
second one if you're paying Patrick
mahomes forty forty-five million dollars
a year yeah so I mean it's smart I don't
know if I believe this room or quite yet
okay first off I think you're gonna have
to trade up pretty high into the first
round to assure that you get yourself a
guy like Henry rugs I think he's in a
ghost somewhere between you know 11 and
22 so that's gonna be a pretty
remarkable jump and you know also I
think right now you've got three
receivers who are burners it's not a
need I understand that but you'll have
other burners come out next year that
draft - all right you know I don't know
if I think that's the wisest decision is
what I'm saying I think there's other
holes to be filled right now in the
Kansas City Chiefs roster and if you're
the Chiefs and you're interested in
doing this you picked your limit you
picked your ceiling you have that's
right deal in place let's say it number
16 number 17 number 18 and if rug's is
still there you do the deal you know
they surely had something like that in
place back in 2017 when they made the
jump up from 27 to 10 to get Patrick
mahomes they weren't gonna make that
trade if my homes wasn't there and maybe
they didn't have anything they they they
played it out they took the chance one
through nine that he wasn't gonna be
picked but they're their limit was 10
and that's where they got him and who
knows what their limit is for rugs maybe
if it's just - 18 or 19 they'll do it if
it's all the way to 11 or 12 Andy they
they're not gonna do it and if he's gone
he's gone and they'll go elsewhere
you